[Music]
thank you
well hello dear friends Welcome to our
program I'd like to know this is a
question and answer program where you
can send us your questions we'll do the
research and if there is an answer we
will try to find the answer we're glad
that you decided to join us today and we
trust that the program will be a
blessing to you if you want to send us
questions uh you'll see the address the
electronic address on the screen it's TV
at some tv.org once again TV at some
tv.org we'd be glad to get your
questions we receive many many of them
which means that you might not get an
answer
immediately but down the road we answer
them in order we should be able to
provide an answer for you if the Bible
addresses the issue I have with me
Daniel Miranda who is an associate
speaker here at Secrets unsealed also in
charge of the Spanish programming here
at our ministry and we're always glad to
have Danielle here with us thank you
Pastor board it's a pleasure for me to
be here in this program it's one of my
favorites amen mine too and I'd like to
ask you to have a word of prayer because
never should we open the Bible without
prayer amen okay let's pray
dear heavenly father return heaven we
thank you for this program and thank you
for the questions that we have received
we do not dare to open your world
without your permission and your
Enlightenment so we pray Lord that you
may guide us in this study at this time
in the name of Jesus amen amen so what's
the first question that we have on the
docket the first question comes from
Johannes and I don't want to Massacre
the last name it's she
shevenars I that's the best thing that's
the best I can do but brother Johannes
he writes from the Netherlands and he
says I have a question related to one of
your statements that's referring to you
in part 10 of the series from the close
of probation to the new Earth I'm an
industrial student always learning from
you very truthful and educational series
only this time I caught it caused a real
confusion
um
it is what you stated at the 19th minute
in that presentation well you refer to
Daniel 11 45
you said that disease is to be
understood as the Mediterranean Sea and
that the tents are military tents this
implies a literal interpretation instead
of a symbolic one
as most prophetic passages Daniel 11 is
highly symbolic and therefore I have
always understood Daniel 11 45 as
follows the Seas represents multitudes
of people
as it says in Revelation 17 15 the tens
represent counterfeit of the true
Sanctuary Tabernacle in heaven and the
glorious holy mountain
of course is Heavenly Mount Zion where
God's people will be finally gathered
and then the whole meaning I thought is
the papacy plants its influence between
the people and the final message hoping
to prevent any more people hearing the
gospel and being saved
so that's the question
okay thank you very much Johannes for
this very insightful question by the way
congratulations for being a deep Bible
student we would
hardly ever receive questions of this
technical nature and so I can tell that
you are doing research you're studying
and I appreciate the fact that you have
this question about what I said so let
me just give you an explanation of the
interpretation that I provided in that
anchor class
we need to understand the progression of
the King of the North
the King of the North Begins in Babylon
and then he moves West
and he overcomes the the countries North
of Israel which would be basically Syria
and then Lebanon then he moved South
and uh and he moves to uh the east of
Jerusalem uh you know Edam Moab and amen
they escaped from his hand which mean
means that he probably is going after
them right and then he continues moving
south uh and he arrives in Ethiopia
Libya and Egypt
so what has happened the King of the
North has basically conquered the known
world of that time right from Babylon to
the river of Egypt in other words he's
overcome the entire world
now Daniel 11 verse the verses are
dealing with the literal progression of
the king of the north but we are to
understand that symbolically
so what happens while the King of the
North is Way South he's basically
overwhelmed the entire holy land and not
only the holy land but the Civilized
world of that day
then Tidings come from the north and
from the East if you look at a map
you're going to find that Libya Egypt
and uh and Ethiopia are Southwest of
Jerusalem
so news from the north and from the East
would be coming from Jerusalem if you
look at a map and what is the message
that's coming from Jerusalem it's the
loud cry
empowered by the latter rain
and it says that this enrages the King
of the North which is the papacy and the
King of the North goes out to annihilate
and Destroy many in other words he he
moves from the south to Jerusalem
between the Mediterranean and God's Holy
Hill and is ready ready to deliver a
final death blow
uh and that's verse 45 says he shall
plant the tents of his Palace between
the Seas and the glorious holy mountain
in other words he's going to try and
overcome the last obstacle to World
Dominion
but then it says he will come to his end
with none to help him
now all of this becomes globalized at
the end of time that's right the King of
the North is no longer literal Babylon
he doesn't move down to literal Egypt
Ethiopia he doesn't really uh you know
attack Edam Moab and amen he doesn't set
the tents of his Palace next to literal
Jerusalem
because this is a global interpretation
Jerusalem represents God's faithful
Remnant who go through the time of
trouble and each of the other nations
has a symbolic value so the picture is
that the papacy is going to place itself
in a strategic place because of a loud
cry because of the latter rain to
deliver a final death blow against God's
people right in fact Ellen White says
very clearly that if he could blot the
remnant from the earth his Triumph would
be complete so that's why I said between
the Mediterranean and the holy land it's
there is megiddo where many battles were
fought against Israel and so that is the
it is a symbolic picture but it is
expressed in literal language right let
me interject a little bit
there is a an important principle when
we deal with Bible prophecy especially
when the imagery is taken from the Old
Testament sometimes we want to jump into
the symbolic meaning but we cannot
understand the symbolic symbolic meaning
without the literal meaning right
because the literal meaning gives us the
the little local interpretation but then
in the New Testament it becomes
worldwide and and spiritual sure but the
worldwide and the spiritual cannot be
understood without the literal and the
local
absolutely it's kind of like in the Old
Testament you have the lamb right in the
New Testament Jesus is the Fulfillment
you have to know the type before you
know the other type you know the lamb
had to be without blemish uh he had to
be you know Sinners had to place their
hand on the head of the Beast and
confess the sin all of this symbolizes
something far greater than the literal
and so in Daniel 11 45 it's expressed in
literal language like the lamb is a
literal animal in the Old Testament but
it has a symbolic uh and Global
fulfillment
so I hope that that's uh helpful that's
the gist of of what I was trying to say
in that particular class
very good thank you Pastor board okay
let's move to our next question that
comes from adoniram
uh actually we have two questions from
him and they are kind of related so we
are going to take both questions
together
um he says here
I have watched most of your anchor and
many other Evangelistic series from
pasobor
and I thank you for your clear
description of Last Day Events and
historicist eschatological
interpretation one thing that puzzles me
in all of these videos why do you focus
so much on the Beast of Revelation 13
instead of warning folks folks about
Satan impersonating Christ as Ellen
White describes in great controversy 588
through 592. this to me seems more
likely to interpret the final verses of
Daniel 11 in Revelation 17 and 18.
it this event precedes Sunday observance
legislation please advise so the second
question is basically the same but he
goes more into details but this is the
gist of the question uh so there are two
questions in one why so much focus on
the Sea Beast of Revelation 13 and if
the counterfeit uh Second Coming by
Satan is before
the Sunday law
so those are the two questions uh so
basically what he's saying is that the
counterfeit second coming of Christ
takes place before the close of
probation exactly four Sunday observance
legislation is what he's saying yes and
uh you know just uh to mention someone
else I'm not going to mention the name
but he says basically that the world is
so divided today you know the Hindus go
their Direction and The Buddhists go
their Direction and the Muslims go the
direction and the Protestants go their
Direction the Catholics go their
Direction says what is it that would
unite the entire world to observe Sunday
and the conclusion with which is a leap
of logic I might say because there's
nothing written that specifically
connects the two the idea is that Satan
is going to counterfeit going to attempt
to counterfeit the second coming of
Christ he's going to appear in dazzling
brightness and you know Ellen White
gives the description of great
controversy and that's going to bring
the whole world together to give Sunday
legislation a global Sunday law
um it sounds plausible it does but the
question is is it in harmony with a
careful study of scripture and so what
we need to do is we need to take a look
at what I believe to be the key which is
Matthew chapter 12. this is going to say
that um yeah Matthew 24 and I know you
have a series on this uh gives us the
last day events in chronological order
because there is the repetition of the
expression and then and then and then
right right so I believe this is a
really good place to go so passivor you
have good points on this okay let's go
to Matthew chapter 24. by the way this
individual in the second uh email that
you didn't read uh he says that he's
that he's watched the entire Matthew 24
series oh okay
um and uh if he has watched Matthew 24
series carefully I don't know how he can
reach the conclusion that he does let me
before we go to the reasons why the
counterfeit second coming or the
attempted counterfeit Second Coming it
takes place before the close of after
the close of probation rather than
before the close of probation let me
just mention something why I mentioned
the Beast so much
and I not only mentioned the Beast a lot
I also mentioned the beast from the
earth a lot yes uh so you know it's it's
a balanced view right uh the reason why
I emphasize the the beast from the sea
is because this Beast is the one that's
going to be the main protagonist at the
end of time like it was during the 1260
years that's right because the Bible
says that it that it actually ruled for
1260 years
it received the deadly wound
but the second beast is going to heal
its deadly wound and it's going to rule
again like it did in the past so why
wouldn't we focus on the Beast of
Revelation 13 the beast from the sea
because the beast from the sea is the
one that lost power and is going to
recover power helped by the second beast
which is the symbol of the United States
of America right and we notice that in
any of the major prophecies of Daniel in
Revelation more time is dedicated to the
symbol that refers to the papacy yes so
in Daniel 2 for example we have the the
feet and there is more to say about the
feet than in Daniel 7 we have the
terrible Beast and the little horn and
the little horn and you know that there
is more that says about that symbol that
then
that the lion or right or the bear again
we see the same thing the little horn in
Daniel 8 yes and then in Daniel 11 we
see the King of the North yeah so the
law of importance God wants to tell us
something like hey focus on this symbol
because it's going to play an important
role in history not only that but this
power is also called the man of sin
right second Thessalonians 2. he's
called the abomination of desolation in
Matthew chapter 24. he's called the
Antichrist in first John uh you know
he's referred to the Harlot in
Revelation 17. so this power is the main
protagonist in Bible prophecy yes the
United States is only instrumental
in uniting church and state
and proclaiming a Sunday law that
eventually will become a global Sunday
law so we need to emphasize uh the Beast
and we also need to emphasize the role
that the second beast has in restoring
power to the first Beast right and of
course with this we don't mean to say
that that's the center of Prophecy we
all understand that Jesus is the center
of course but of course how this place
in The Last Day Events yeah but you know
but you talk about Antichrist
which doesn't necessarily mean against
Christ it means one who tries to occupy
the place of Christ you can't talk about
the person who tries to take the place
of Christ without talking about Christ
correct because he's counterfeiting he's
trying to counterfeit uh everything
related to Christ the sanctuary this you
know the the intercession of Christ
and everything else
okay so now let's let's show why the
counterfeit second coming when I say
counterfeit second coming we understand
that that it is it is not the true one
in other words it's Satan attempting to
imitate the second coming of Christ the
genuine second coming of Christ there
are several reasons I have here why the
counterfeit Second Coming where Satan
attempts to do it applies
after the close of probation not before
the close of probation the first reason
you mentioned which is that Matthew 24
this person says Matthew 24 is a chiasm
there's no proof that Matthew 24 is a
chiasm you know some people find chiasms
everywhere in scripture and sometimes I
think they're kind of forced but but
Matthew 24 is a sequential series of
events yeah I'm Sorry by the way it
would be good to explain what a chiasm
is for those who do not know what a
chiasm is go ahead
um well chiasm basically is a way in
which some prophecies and texts are
structure in which you can see parallels
from the beginning and the ending points
and it's called chiasm comes from the
kai which is a Greek letter kind of like
an ex so that's why this is called a
chiasm yeah but Matthew you cannot do
that with Matthew 24. I mean if you take
the first verses of Matthew 24 and the
last verses there is no way that you
there's no harm in you there is no
Harmony between them so it's more
sequential than chiastic right and the
evidence that it's sequential and we
need to read these verses we're going to
have to dedicate more than one program
to answer this question
let's look at all the temporal
expressions in Matthew 24 that show that
this chapter is in chronological order
let's go to Matthew chapter 24. I'll
have you read the verses Matthew 24 and
verse 6. okay verse 6 I'm reading from
the new King James version it says and
you will hear of wars and rumors of wars
see that you are not troubled for all
these things must come to pass but the
end is not yet see the end there's not
yet and then read verse 7. fornation
will rise against nation and Kingdom
against Kingdom and there will be
famines pestilences and earthquakes in
various places
that's verse 7. and verse 8 and
all these are the beginning of Sorrows
okay so you have a sequence yeah the end
is not yet these things are the
beginning of Sorrows and then read verse
verse 8 9 verse 9. the then they will
deliver you up to tribulation and kill
you and you will be hated by All Nations
for my name's sake so what is it that
leads to the hatred against God's
faithful people all the crisis the
pestilences famine Wars Nation against
Nation so there there's a connection the
word then then by the way let me say
something about the word then
there is a word that is sometimes
translated then which is a very common
word in the New Testament it's a
preposition the the preposition Kai Kai
for example in Revelation 13 11 after
The Sea Beast rules it says then I saw
another Beast rise from the earth well
the word there is not the same word as
here it says and I really it would be
and I saw another Beast the word Kai
that connects with what was before
the word that is used here is the Greek
word tote
it's used multiple times in the New
Testament
it refers to one event taking place
immediately after another event in
chronological order
it's not the word guy it's the word tote
so let's keep that in mind as we go
through Matthew chapter 24 and look at
all the references that's that's used
nine times in Matthew chapter 24 for
sequential events uh so it says as a
result of the disasters then God's
people are going to be hated
then let's read verse 10. and then many
will be offended will and then many will
be offended will betray one another and
will hate one another
okay so uh in verse 9 it says that these
disasters are going to lead persecution
against God's people and then verse 10
says that many of those who were friends
and relatives are going to turn against
God's faithful people it identifies
who's going to turn against God's people
right and then notice of verse 14 the
word then again
okay
verse 14 and this Gospel of the Kingdom
will be preached in all the world as a
witness to all the nations and then the
end will come okay verse 16 verse 16.
then let those who are in Judea flee to
the mountain that's after the
abomination of those desolation is set
up in verse 15 it says what are we
supposed to do as a result of that those
who are in Judea flee to the mountains
okay and then verse 19
but woe to those who are pregnant and
those who are nursing babies in those
days in those days which days well the
the days where people are fleeing
exactly and then verse 21.
for then there will be Great Tribulation
such as has not been since the beginning
of the world until this time no nor ever
shall be okay then comes a Great
Tribulation then verse 22. and unless
those days were shortened the days of
the Great Tribulation uh no flesh would
be saved but for the elect's sake those
days will be shortened notice those days
temporal expression those days referring
to what the Great Tribulation verse 23
then if anyone says to you look here is
the Christ or there do not believe it
for verse 24 for false Christ and false
prophets will arise and show great signs
and wonders to deceive if possible even
the elect so when the sound Satan
counterfeit the second Ellen White
quotes these verses of Matthew chapter
24 in the chapter on the time of trouble
in great controversy
so so when is Satan going to attempt to
counterfeit the second coming of Christ
during the Great Tribulation it says
Dear in the tribulation in those days
then notice verse verse 29 once again a
temporal expression immediately after
the tribulation of those days the sun
will be darkened and the moon will not
give its light the Stars will fall from
Heaven and the powers of the heavens
will be shaken immediately after the
tribulation the Great Tribulation where
he had the counterfeit the counterfeit
coming of Christ
which is called the Great Tribulation
and then in verse 30 the word then is
used twice
then the sign of the son of man will
appear in heaven and then all the tribes
of the earth will mourn and they will
see the son of man coming on the Clouds
Of Heaven with power and great Glory so
is there a sequential a clear sequential
order of events yes there is in Matthew
chapter 24. absolutely there's
absolutely no doubt whatsoever
furthermore the interesting thing is
when you examine the book last day
events which is a compilation of
quotations by Ellen White
the chapters are ordered according to
the order of events at the end of time
and the Order of events in the book Last
Day Events are an identical order to the
ones that we find in Matthew chapter 24.
so
so you know very clearly we're dealing
with events that are in chronological
order another important Point uh and we
only have just a few minutes left
another important point is that Ellen
White places the Satan's attempt to
counterfeit the second coming
in the chapter on the time of trouble
and the chapter begins with quoting
Daniel chapter 12 verse 1 and then El
white speaks about the clothes of
Probation and then comes a time of
trouble so she doesn't put the
counterfeit second coming of Christ uh
in the chapter uh the previous one which
is the final warning which is a loud cry
and the outpouring of the latter rain
she puts the the counterfeits that can
come in of uh that Satan tries attempts
to counterfeit she places it in the
chapter in the time of trouble because
clearly the counterfeit second coming by
Satan is going to take place during the
time of trouble after the close of
probation another important point is
that during this period God's people are
crying out for deliverance
um I want to take a few minutes now to
read Ellen White's description of the
counterfeit Second Coming
and this is this is long great
controversary 6 24 and 625 I don't think
we're going to be able to finish it in
the time that we have in this particular
period but we'll we'll deal with it in
the next program okay but let's begin
this is great controversy uh Pages 6 24
and 6 25.
as the crowning Act
what is the crowning act it's the last
the Final Act
in the great drama of deception Satan
himself will personate Christ
the church has long professed to look to
the savior's Advent as the consummation
of her hopes
Now The Great Deceiver will make it
appear that Christ has come
in different parts of the earth Satan
will manifest himself among men as a
majestic being of dazzling brightness
resembling the description of the Son of
God given by John in the Revelation the
glory that surrounds him is unsurpassed
by anything that mortal eyes have yet
beheld the shout of Triumph rings out
upon the air Christ has come Christ has
come
the people prostrate themselves in
adoration before him well he lifts up
his hands and pronounces a blessing upon
them as Christ bless his disciples when
he was upon the Earth
his voice is soft and subdued Yet full
of Melody in gentle and compassionate
tones he presents some of the same
gracious Heavenly truths which the
savior uttered he heals the diseases of
the people and then in his assumed
character of Christ he claims to have
changed the Sabbath to Sunday and
commands all that hell of the day which
he has commands all to Hell the day
which he has blessed he declares that
those who persist in keeping holy the
seventh day are blaspheming his name by
refusing to listen to his angels
sent to them with light and Truth
this is the strong over almost over
mastering delusion
like the Samaritans who were deceived by
Simon Magus the multitudes from the
least to the greatest give heed to these
sorceries saying this is the great power
of God so several important things
you'll try to personate Christ you'll
make it appear that Christ came he's
going to appear as a majestic being his
glorious unsurpassed by more lies people
shout that Christ has come he pronounces
a blessing upon them with a subdued
voice and Ellen White says this is a
strong over almost over mastering
delusion remember that because in the
next program I'm going to read the rest
of this statement as well as two others
that locate when the kind of a second
coming takes place thank you for being
with us God bless
foreign
[Music]